[Music]
from the directors of the matrix and
nothing else worth mentioning comes the
last time anyone will give them with
cows keys money easiest money we ever
made Jupiter ascending lookout
Scientology there's a new ridiculous
space opera in town and it makes even
less sense than Battlefield Earth so
full of such terrible performances
stupid dialog my mother wrote her future
self into hell well and ridiculous
characters that it's actually kind of
hilarious I create life and I destroy it
audiences claim they're hungry for
original films that aren't sequels
adaptations or remakes just not like
this as the Wachowskis roll out their
signature blend of cgi bullsh
lazy philosophy how could I be a
reincarnation if your mother unless her
mother was from Earth and a story about
the human race being harvested as a life
force for a more advanced civilization
yep that again if you've been waiting
for a female sci-fi lead character on
par with Ripley or Sarah Connor get
ready to keep waiting as Mila Kunis
spends the entire movie getting saved
cleaning toilets getting saved again
desperately trying to bone her Savior
getting saved again playing dress-up
cleaning more toilets and looking bored
because anything we can do to make the
journey easy and you let us know
actually you know what I'm feeling a
little overdressed so if you maybe have
something that I could change into you
just found out aliens exist wake up but
she's not alone ride passively along
with Academy Award winner Eddie Redmayne
who makes a strong case for the Academy
to retro actively take back his Academy
Award
harvest that planet tomorrow before I
and Channing Tatum the hottest guy in
the world who does his best to hide
under a bunch of eyeliner a ginger chin
strap and space rollerskates they use
the force of gravity redirecting it into
differential equations though so you can
see yeah so settle in for a plot so
ridiculous we're just gonna tell you
what happens this is actually the story
me Jupiter the child of an astronomer
who's murdered while trying to defend
his house hoteles go Jupiter's world
will change when on the way to donate
her eggs for money to buy a telescope of
her own intergalactic bounty hunters
attack her on behalf of the abrasax
siblings an ancient family of business
moguls who killed the dinosaurs
your people kill the dinosaurs they seed
planets with human beings then kill and
harvest them to create regenexx a serum
of eternal life Jupiter it turns out is
an exact genetic copy of the abrasax
dead mother sarahfey which makes her the
rightful owner of the entire planet
earth and a pawn in the abrasax sibling
rivalry the first person to reach
Jupiter however is Caine wise a half
albino man wolf hybrid who's also a
hoverboard expert Jupiter who can
control bees due to their ability to
recognize royalty finds herself falling
for her protector Cain but since a
disgraced man will splice as no suitable
match for reincarnation of a Razak's
royalty they can't be together I have
more in common with
Jupiter is tricked into accepting a
marriage proposal from Titus abrasax who
claims he will keep the universe safe
Cain and his own comrade stinger a
fellow at space Cobb who is also part be
rescued Jupiter just before the ceremony
is complete saving her from marrying a
man who's not just thousands of years
older than her but is also technically
her son and plans to murder her and
that's just the beginning of Jupiter's
problems as back on earth her mom boss
and coworkers are captured by balem
abrasax dinosaur henchman mr. greeghan
shortly thereafter her cane and stinger
must launch another nearly identical
rescue mission saving the person Jupiter
on the planet Jupiter destroying the
regenexx Factory and killing balem
safely back in Chicago Cain who has
angel wings now by the way it's free to
hover skate with a new queen of the
earth who after all is said and done
uses her knowledge of the universe and
royal power to clean toilets again
completely ignoring the other two
abrasax siblings who are still very much
running a planetary holocaust business
the end and that's really just the
basics are you sure these are the same
guys who made the matrix starring
Cinderella in space Sean D Brian Boitano
larry and lana wachowski Koopas max rebo
a the mouse and rat maid which house
keys descending
wait Sean Bean dies in every good movie
but survives this one man they couldn't
even kill Sean Bean right be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers for
you the day bison graced your village
was the most important day of your life
but for me it was Tuesday you
embarrassed me in front of her you gotta
eat the booty like groceries seeing does
not contain a lap dance oh what a day
what a lovely day I record these things
when I'm on the toilet